vous restez avec nous on va parler d'un
autre rendez-vous le city raid à présent
on change de commune de
voisins-le-bretonneux à montigny le
bretonneux le city raid c'est un
parcours d'orientation en milieu urbain
à la découverte une douzaine de lieux
institutionnels sportifs culturels dans
la ville pour les jeunes de 10 à présent
opération nationale une cinquantaine de
villes pour cette saison 2013 et la
finale nationale à paris elle le
mercredi 19 juin sur montigny et
l'opération l'étape régionale ce sera le
17 avril ce n'est pas la première fois
que vous l'organiser ça veut dire que
c'est positif est que ça apporte
beaucoup à ces jeunes de 10 à 13 ans oui
énormément
c'est la troisième édition donc
énormément puisque l'objectif essentiel
c'est d'amener les jeunes vers la
citoyenneté de manière ludique pour leur
faire découvrir nos partenaires
institutionnels que sont bas la mairie
les services internes de la mairie mais
également des partenaires externes la
police municipale la police nationale
les pompiers les anciens combattants et
des images des précédentes éditions avec
plus tôt par ailleurs les enfants qui
partent très très très vite mais c'est
pas une course c'est vraiment comme
parcours d'orientation comment ça se
déroule justement tout au long de la
journée parce que ça dure toute la joie
à l'horizon une feuille ils ont une
feuille de route avec les différents
points de contrôle que ce mois sont
constitués par les différents
partenaires sur lesquels ils doivent eux
passés avec des questions et des
réponses sont multiples idées au travers
du questionnement
c'est de créer justement du lien avec
les différents accueillons sur ces
différents sur ces différents points de
contrôle
donc ça génère la discussion sache nerfs
du lien ça permet de découvrir les
métiers des missions de chacun l'idée
effectivement au travers de toussaint
c'est de l'est de les sensibiliser à
leur environnement qui vont des
transports publics mais aussi
fictivement l'armée la police les
pompiers etc et ça permet à ces jeunes
peut-être d'avoir un autre regard sur ce
monde qui les entoure et c'était un
petit peu l'idée initiale lorsque cette
opération a été créée par bruno pomart
ya onze ans maintenant
ressenti véritablement sur le terrain ça
change le rapport par exemple avec les
pompiers la police les jeunes les voient
différemment
oui absolument l'échangé très riche et
constructif pour les deux les deux
partenaires mais pour l'enfance et c'est
une très bonne démarche
d'ailleurs cette démarche qui est à la
fois citoyenne et donc pédagogique est
reconnu par l'éducation nationale et
nous remercions infiniment nos
partenaires privilégiés que sont les
chefs d'établissement parce que les
établissements participent tous vos
partenaires vous en avez mentionné
quelques-uns les pompiers par exemple
qui participe ça veut dire qu'ils sont
véritablement impliqués et qu'eux aussi
doivent travailler et s'y préparent et
manteufel il prépare un questionnaire
questions réponses et puis quelques
épreuves où ces phrases ils vont gagner
ils vont manier la langue sont dit le
designer
forcément ça plaît et puis c'est
effectivement une vraie découverte je
veux dire du coup ces jeunes portent un
autre regard sur sur tout ce petit monde
il ya deux ans maintenant à la deuxième
édition l'avait organisé un vote en
conditions réelles à l'hôtel de ville
pour l'enfer aussi découvrir ce que
c'est qu'un vote avec les bulletins de
vote les urnes extérieure n'est pris
comme prétexte les différents
partenaires de manière assez étonnante
mais presque logique j'ai envie de dire
les trois premiers la police nationale
les pompiers l'armée voilà cette ville
exactement
et puis il ya une espèce de petite
compétition aussi entre les partenaires
qui se sont pris au jeu
donc pour les solliciter c'est devenu
très facile entre guillemets et puis à
chaque fois c'est le développement
nouveaux moyens et seul ou deux
surprises qui nous révèle à chaque fois
donc c'est extrêmement enthousiasmant et
des enfants leur semble de ça se passe
et individuelles whisky par son équipe
son équipe ce sont des équipes de six
enfants avec un encadrant indult
l'encadrant adulte est vraiment là en
fait pour accompagner l'équipe mais ne
doit pas participer aux réponses etc etc
ce terrain c'est plus un garde-fou en
fait sur la sécurité
différents points comme ça ils ont donc
une feuille de route avec les différents
points de contrôle trois questions par
point de contrôle où il épreuve qui peut
être sportives intellectuelles etc ce
terrain là cette année on leur on leur a
préparé un petit puzzle un peu
particulier donc voilà ils vont
découvrir ça et donc effectivement il
donc il ya un départ le matin aux
alentours de 9h30 10h un retour
obligatoire sur un temps donné pour
qu'ils aient une vraie pause déjeuner
ils les organise même leur cheminement
nous on impose le premier point de
contrôle de façon à s'assurer que les
quarante ou cinquante équipes qu'on va
voir ça n'est vont bien se répartir sur
l'ensemble parce que sinon ça créerait
des bouchons et l'après-midi pareil donc
il organise leur parcours on impose en
fonction de ce qu'ils ont fait à nouveau
premier point de contrôle pour l'après
midi retour 16h30
là on fera le vote pendant ce temps là
en corrige les questionnaires il y en
aura un certain nombre et remise des
résultats aux alentours de 17h15 17h30
c'est par éclipser une petite
compétition derrière un vainqueur
oui tout à fait il y en aura quatre
participants à paris généralement on
prend les trois premiers et puis on
détermine une équipe du fair play
ces quatre équipes renault mènera à
paris charléty le 19 juin prochain
comment on détermine l'équipe du fair
play ah ça c'est du point de contrôle
c'est les différents partenaires sur les
points déterminants
c'est en fonction de l'intérêt du
comportement l'enthousiaste on a un
petit symbole spécial qui permet de
marquer ça et ça veut dire que comme il
ya des vainqueurs qui vont ensuite
participé à paris il faut forcément
briller il faut représenter
montigny-le-bretonneux
vous l'avez coach et ensuite vous les
prenez en main et vous leur dites là
maintenant ça rigole plus c'était sympa
à montigny mai à paris va falloir faire
mieux
voilà c'est lui en voulait encadrer
comme ça et vous leur dites est ce que
montigny c'est bien et c'est bien
illustré par le passé
ce que montigny a déjà
oublié on a eu un jeune qui avait
terminé deuxième sur une épreuve
individuelle
je crois que c'est autour de la box ou
du goût de la lutte quelque chose comme
ça
non c'était sur le rugby parce qu'un
petit malin il s'est dit comme la finale
a lieu à charléty c'est un grand stade
de rugby donc qu'il avait potassé les
questions possibles sur ses malheurs et
il a brillé comme ça réviser et puis sur
les centaines d' équipe qui participe on
a eu des équipes qui sont placés 25/30
c'est plutôt parisse et c'est
particulier c'est pour le coup une vraie
grosse journée là on en voit
effectivement là c'est très important
puisque cette année encore il ya une
cinquantaine de villes donc si à chaque
ville hong kong soit 3 4 équipes
qualifiées
il a multiplié pour le nombre de jeunes
qui sont présents ce sera au mois de
juin juste avant d'arriver au mois de
juin il faut tout de même que les
épreuves heure locale se dérouler se
déroule bien et vous appelez toujours
les bénévoles à venir vous rejoindre
tout à fait mais maman qui peuvent
encadrer les angles a besoin de parents
et puis cette année donc particularité
l'épreuve a lieu donc clos 17 avril
mais les clôture des inscriptions c'est
pour le 3 avril
ce qu'on doit remonter on fait à
l'organisation nationale tous les
dossiers que les autorisations
parentales donc réellement la clôture
des inscriptions
c'est le 3 avril mais qui vous que tout
le monde se prépare et se bouge
maintenant comme je d'inscription le 3
avril le city raid se déroulera le
mercredi 17 avril à montigny le
bretonneux et puis la 33e course du
printemps le 31 mars
donc dès 8h45 il faudra être matinal en
plus pour pouvoir déguster les trophées
en chocolat on viendra filmer on viendra
voir si justement l'artisan chocolatier
a bien travaillé pour les récompenses
merci à tous les trois ont parlé de
l'enfant que justement et la protection
de l'enfance est une compétence
obligatoire pour le département et dans
les yvelines le conseil général gère
notamment le foyer de versailles c'est
d'ailleurs depuis ce site que les
grandes lignes du plan en 2013 de
protection de l'enfance ont été
dévoilées reportage romain gravette et
patrick jacques de dixmude billard baby
foot jeux vidéo ici nous ne sommes pas
dans un service jeunesse mais dans un
service d'accueil d'urgence pour un
adolescent
ouvert depuis un an ce service
départementale reçoit quatre filles et
quatre garçons âgés de 14 à 18 ans dans
90% des cas ces adolescents sont placés
dans cet établissement sur décision
judiciaire
il reste trois mois le temps de se
reconstruire là je sors pas donc chez
base des tiges n'est pas en danger
cherche un travail pour l'année
prochaine ce que je faisais pas quand
j'étais chez moi j'ai les périples des
éducateurs spécialisés sont présents 24
heures sur 24 dans ce foyer robert
carpentier situé à versailles un service
d'urgence j'ai accepté le fait d'être
séparé de sa famille quelle que soit la
raison et de pouvoir imaginer la façon
dont ils vont pouvoir rebondir pour
demain il ya plusieurs portes de sortie
c'est un retour en famille donc au tour
dans le milieu naturel
un millier l'argile parce que c'est pas
forcément les parents tant que tel après
il ya des foyers des foyers ce qu'on
appelle des maisons d'enfants à
caractère social des familles d'accueil
des lieux de vie ou alors effectivement
pour certains jeunes des séjours de
rupture à l'étranger
cette aide aux adolescents est une
mission obligatoire du conseil général
qui consacre 7,5 millions d'euros au
fonctionnement de ce service d'urgence
et des structures départementales comme
celle d'un cas nous trouvons ici la
maison de l'enfance et puis il ya des
structures aussi associative qui sont
dans l'ensemble du département voire
voir au delà du time it territoriales du
département
le budget global de protection de
l'enfance dans le département deux
villes est de 80 millions d'euros qui
sont principalement les prés de journée
que nous payons au
aux structures d'accueil des enfants qui
sont en place et deux établissements aux
paix qui a un autre qui sortira de terre
à mantes-la-jolie au premier semestre
2015 remplacement ce foyer limité en
nombre ils pourront accueillir 26
adolescents